I am saying that H let say yes or no
let's say yes or no do I believe that
heavenly father would keep her out of
the Celestial Kingdom if she decides
continues to have lesbian relationships
I yes hi my name is Gen and I explore
social and controversial issues through
both sides and I'll be moderating this
episode of middleground Mormons versus
ex Mormons and the first prompt is
Mormonism is a
cult you know I think some of the things
that are important to pay attention to
were like critical things in your life
that you're told how you're supposed to
do them right like your sexuality the
way you dress what you
eat what underwear you wear MH what made
me finally cuz it was hard to admit
growing up Mormon it was hard to admit
that it was a cult but I think when you
look at again the critical thinking the
lack of it um I think is a big red flag
I feel like with Mormonism and growing
up in that culture
which is their that word right there I
had no issue stepping forward but not
necessarily to specifically focus on the
negative connotation but really just
what the word is let's call it what it
is I'll just speak kind of from a
psychological perspective because that's
my background uh does the organization
uh you know withhold information from
its
members uh with the intent of
controlling the thoughts of the members
does the organization manipulate uh the
members through a motion and do they
have excessive controls and behavior and
while U it's deeply offensive to tell
anyone they're a member of a cult no
one's going to ever say they're a member
of a cult because no one thinks they're
an a cult can we have the disagreer step
forward so I'm a convert to the church
and and uh born and raised in a part
member family uh lived a gay lifestyle
before I joined the church and I
um it's it's a little um
disingenuous to me when people say that
the church tried to hide stuff from me
because I grew up in a in a family that
was very stereotypical so just very
strict and I remember things being
talked about like um polygamy like lots
of sensitive church history topics
growing up and that's partially why when
I distance myself from Christianity
generally to go live a gay life style um
I really had concerns with the church
but ultimately knowing those things only
strengthened my testimony when I came
back to it I completely left that
lifestyle behind and of course I still
have same sex attraction and but um I am
definitely happier now being married to
a woman having kids um than I was with
my boyfriends when I think of a a cult I
think of an organization that's really
controlling and they don't let you
exercise Freedom or autonomy they
control what you how you think they
control what you say and how you say it
but if I look at Mormon culture
expansively I don't see people that are
controlled I know I I feel like the word
cult I if if you break it down to mean
at some point someone suggested that I
live my life a certain way then
everything's Ault and if everything's
Ault then nothing's Ault there are many
me members of the church who have this
mindset that when the prophet speaks the
debate is over and you should just not
think about it and that's not right
I honestly I think that is cultish um
but that is not what the church has
taught over time I think though that you
are told seek your own answer pray but
if it differs from what the prophet is
saying then you might be being deceived
by Satan or you got the wrong answer it
should ultimately align with what the
prophet is saying and that's why they
say you know read the book of Mormon
pray see if it's true for yourself and
if if you don't get an answer pray
harder go talk to someone have more
experiences try again until you get the
right answer that it's true so I think
it's a little disingenuous to say that
you can seek truth on your
own that doesn't align with the prophet
because that doesn't generally just seem
to be how it goes yeah but that
completely goes in the face of I was a
missionary for two years and the number
one message we do when we present The
Book of Mormon and Mormonism at large to
some
is the infamous I promise we say
go home pray about it you need to
develop a relationship with God that is
so unique and strong that you can
recognize when he is talking to you
whether or not this is the path you're
supposed to take the idea that Mormonism
is a cult is a perjorative Trope that
has been an anti-mormon slur against the
church for a long time and I always ask
by what rubric you mentioned the bite
model before and I've seen that you've
interviewed uh Steven Hassan on your
show
and he's given a rubric well that same
author has called anybody that voted for
Donald Trump a cult he wrote an entire
book about the The Cult of trump and if
you apply any of these bite model
methodologies or any of these cult
definitions my show choir in high school
was a cult apple is a cult wait until
the next Star Wars movie comes out it's
a cult that word is used in the same way
with the same
inefficacy and the inability to back it
up unless you use people that
unfortunately in your case were not
actually being truly Mormon Steven
Hassen would agree that Apple can have
some of the traits of the cult or the
military or an educational institution
or a corporation but he also has a harm
continue a Continuum of harm and if you
add up all the deaths of of the people's
Temple Jim Jones of of you know any of
the Cults you mentioned it it won't add
up to the number of LGBT youth in the
Mormon church that have killed
themselves and so we can talk about just
severity of you know children are cut
off some children are homeless because
their parents kick them out now I'll
admit the Mormon church does a lot of
good for a lot of people but if you just
add up the amount of harm I think that's
that's when it goes from just a silly
Trope to a very serious conversation I I
can't vouge and say that an organization
as large as the LDS Church
had doesn't have any damage obviously
people can do damage but at the same
token If We Hold every organization to a
standard that implies they can't have
any sort of cultural stains that the
entire country has struggled with well
good luck and as someone who believes in
Jesus Christ My Hope and my goal is we
can get rid of it we can get rid of that
out of our church eventually but that is
not a unique Mormon problem that is a
problem that was given to us by the
Generations that came before the
generations that said separate water
fountains the generations that said oh
you're gay you should be going to Camp
whether it's a Baptist Mormons whatever
that stuff is evil but does that evil
make us uniquely evil or is that a
western American problem that has
permeated these organizations the Mormon
Community welcomes the lgbtq
community so as a game member of the
church I truly believe that I feel
welcome I feel at home in the church I I
realize some people have an issue with
obviously we have the doctrine that
sexual expression should only between be
be between a married man and woman but
that same standard applies to everyone
and the scriptures are clear that male
and female black and white Bond and free
all are welcome to come into Christ and
that's the purpose of the church the
church agrees that
no matter like what you are who you are
and who you love they're not going to
shun you because of that you might not
get the same privileges necessarily but
that doesn't in the church what do you
want privileges like such as like going
to the temple that kind of a privilege
so yeah that but that also is the same
for straight people if if you're not
living the law of chassity and your
straight you could have Temple recommend
as well it's very personal but the
church doesn't the church doesn't
specifically when you're invited to
church they don't come up to you and ask
you are you straight they're very
welcome are you straight are you lesbian
are you gay they they ask you about
yourself you have to fill out a form no
oh see when I walked in I had to fill
out a form no can the disagreer please
step forward
please the concept that straight people
and gay people have it equally hard to
enter the temple is a complete joke
because straight people yes also have to
deal with their trials and their faith
and live the law of Chastity do X Y and
Z and yet they're not having to go
against their instincts or their nature
it's all lined up for them like if we
were to flip it and say that being gay
is the norm in the church let's just
pretend for a second and you were the
straight one and you wanted to go to the
temple and in order to go to the temple
you would have to swear to never sleep
with women again and you would only be
able to sleep with men that would feel
very wrong to you no I I I I completely
understand we live in a hypersexualized
society and I think that is very very
difficult for gay lesbian transgender
members of the church and so on and so
forth and just as Timber said the Lord
in his infinite Mercy does not spare any
of us from trials but this
idea that I don't want to say their
their trial is unique because it is
unique but I I look at it a little bit
differently I have leukemia my illness
will kill me 20 years earlier than
tber you don't
think you don't think on my
deathbed forgive
me you don't think that I wouldn't trade
a little bit of Timber's
gayness for 20 years extra on this
Earth so if temp
has a loss of Faith because being gay in
a hypersexualized world with a law of
Chastity from the Bible that he doesn't
understand I get that because we live in
a cruel hypersexualized
world but I stare down the barrel of a
chemotherapy pill every day that keeps
me alive I will die probably the same
time my father does it it's a trial and
it sucks but welcome to the club that's
why I have to stop you right there to
say that being gay is a trial is
disgusting that is offensive you don't
think dying early is disgusting to me
let her finish I am saying that the way
that the church sees people being born
gay is like being born with cancer I
think yeah I think she was more upset
that you referred you you basically
cified it as an illness a l because of
it being gay is not a trial being gay in
the church is a trial because of how
they treat you and how they see it how
they see gay people is like being born
with cancer they're like we're so sorry
you were born this way you can be that
way but don't do anything about it if I
being I went to BYU I took tests where
they said If by they had asked questions
like how do we treat members of the
lgbtq community and the answer was to
love them unconditionally but understand
that they will never be truly as happy
as those who follow the Mormon religion
and so that is so painful to read and
see because the trial isn't being gay
actually being gay is incredible being
attracted to someone of the same sex is
beautiful and I've never been happier
the trial comes when the church tells
you that that is wrong and hopefully
when you die that cancer of being gay
will be gone that's the I I don't I see
I I disagree I think we all have equal
opportunity for happiness I think
happiness looks different for other
people and I can say say that I had a
semblance of Happiness when I was with
my boyfriends and um but are you saying
she's not really happy are you saying
her happiness is fake I'm not I'm not I
believe that I believe you are truly
happy and you think she'll need to
change fundamentally who she is as a
person when we're talking about the next
life in order to get that happiness that
you're looking that you're that you're
bringing to the I believe the Christian
doctrine that sexual ual expression
should only be be between a man and a
woman but that again that's not an LDS
Doctrine so will Mormon Heavenly Father
keep her out of the Celestial Kingdom if
she continues to have gay relationships
he's not I as him I am saying that let's
say yes or no let say yes or no do I
believe that heavenly father would keep
her out of the Celestial Kingdom if she
if she continues to have lesbian
relationships through the through her
entire life and and doesn't repent for
them I yes I believe that yes but but
he'll keep her he'll keep her out of
Heaven Celestial King Celestial Kingdom
Celestial Kingdom yes we all have a
standard that we need she won't be able
to live with her family forever which is
the Mormon promise no but that's
that's of the doct of Eternal hold on
hold on hold on keep going I mean I yes
I I believe Jesus is clear in the
scriptures that there is a certain way
to uh be able to return to the father
and we have to be willing to sacrifice
everything he says
he says that we need to lay down our
lives deny ourselves to follow him in
order to go to heaven and whether you
believe it's the Celestial Kingdom or
heaven or whatever it is there there is
a standard that we need to live by that
standard it also applies to several
other religions I just don't want that
to get confused that it's oh it's
specifically our Mormon religion that's
what I'm saying yeah exactly it's
several other religions it's not just
this panel is about the LDS church
though we we definitely talk about the
issues with the LDS church there's two
ways to be accepted in the Mormon church
if you're gay you either can be celibate
or you can enter into a mixed
orientation marriage and I can tell you
that uh there's like a 70% divorce rate
for mixed orientation marriages let me
just finish let me just it is true so I
have a PhD in clinical Counseling
psychology I interviewed 1,612 LGBT
Mormons and X Mormons and this is based
on my published research data and let me
just finish so you have one choice which
is to be in a mixed orientation marriage
where 70% are going to fail and you're
going to be likely miserable or you can
be celibate and believe it or not being
celibate has worse depression anxiety
and mental health outcomes as someone
who's in a mixed orientation marriage
and that's why so many lgbtq Mormons
choose death and if you want personal
I'll give you personal I am married to a
man who used to be married to a woman an
amazing amazing woman who God definitely
had me find because of the situation
that I had I was able to have two
biological children with this woman and
there is no way I believe in a god that
is going to take away my husband and my
two biological children that he
absolutely gave me I have them I love
them and I will have them forever I
think statistics are very important but
I'm very curious would you say you're
happier now than before yes because my
joy the joy that I feel in Christ is so
much deeper than the
emotional physical connection that I had
with my boyfriends it doesn't compare
much joy in Christ right now can I just
interject let's let's just and we can so
it might be the only formor who didn't
step forward um you know I think two
things can be true at once
so obviously members of the church by
and large are good people who don't hate
anyone but at the same time we got to be
realistic gay people aren't going
anywhere and Mormons aren't going
anywhere so what do you do and and the
future of LGBT relations and the church
I'm excited to see what happens because
clearly something's going to have to
happen there's something's going to have
to change because these are two groups
that are not leaving masturbation is
sinful agre your please step
forward women and men are equal in the
church agre please step
forward
jeez this is a one of the most glorious
doctrines of the Church of Jesus Christ
of lday saints is there's no other
church or religion on the earth that
teaches that men and women eventually
can become uh Gods co-creators and a and
co-equal partners I mean we we do
believe currently that that we are
co-equal Partners already just different
responsibilities but we both have the
same ability to become kings and queens
priests and priestesses and that's the
ultimate goal I wholeheartedly believe
that men and women in the church are
equal but I I think it's important to
Define what equal is because I'm
immediately aware of what the secular
anti- Mormon arguments are at the same
time I I look at our faith and we're a
faith that has codified this idea as the
Apostle Paul said that we will be
co-participants in his glory and we have
a relief society which is the largest
women's organization in the world we're
one of the only faiths that's mainstream
or large enough to have National
recognition that I know of that has a
doctrine of heavenly mother that is
actually sung about in our official hym
book uh you look at women they don't
need to receive the priesthood in order
to go to the temple they um
we're told our priesthood as men that we
hold is useless unless it's applied
through longsuffering and patience and
we're constantly told that you are
living the Adam and Eve archetype and
unless you make a decision mutually with
your wife which is the ultimate
definition of equality it's uh what we
call unrighteous Dominion um I'm very
aware that some people say oh because
women can't have the priesthood that
you're a second class Citizen and there
some cultural arguments that people
might try and bring in but in the
codified faith women
enjoy sometimes will complain about
almost preferential
treatment does anyone know who the
Relief Society president is like can you
name the woman that is the Relief
Society president over the whole
church I I I I know it was Jean B
Bingham I don't know who it is right now
I'll be honest with you
I definitely think that men and women
are treated very different that said I
can't name Apostles I can't name the 12
apostles so yeah you could name probably
the first three president Nelson and his
counselors I I could name the prophet
yes but at any given time I confess I
stay on track stay on track stay TR I do
not think men and women are treated
equally and it goes beyond the
priesthood it also be goes to your
duties as a women I think a lot of the
time women are told I mean a lot of
women go to BYU or college just to find
and they're told not to continue their
education once they get married and to
let the man take over and be the main
bread winner so I I think that there's a
lot of there is a difference between the
duties of men and women in the church I
sorry I think I think that's just a a
general critique of judeo
Christian traditional household uh
standards I guess or Customs I do
believe women have
marginalized and um men have asserted
their Authority and power over them in
unrighteous ways and unrighteous
Dominion right uh but I think that has
definitely changed especially like um
not to get in the specifics of the
temple but the temple used to say that
that women are basically subject to
their husbands and have access to God
through their husbands and they would
Veil their faces as well that's not
there anymore and I think that is that
is a positive step that the church is
coming to ack knowled that hey if
heavenly father and heavenly mother are
co-creators co- Goods they're she's not
subject to Heavenly Father in Judaism
sorry in Judaism really quickly women
can be rabbis and I I don't know if
within the nextend depending on the sure
I can't see women being Bishops
personally when I go to my church when
I'm in my ward when I come to church I
sit down everybody leading the church is
a male and the only female you'll see on
the stand she is playing the organ and
when she's not playing the org she comes
back down and she'll sit with her
family is that why you I want to know
why you chose to stay back CU I thought
that was very significant uh because I I
agree I I don't believe they're equal
like just just like what I said she's
she goes up she plays organ she comes
back down and all you're left with is
men until other women come up later on
to Bear their testimony or sing
something how have you felt your
involvement has been as a woman my
involvement um I was personally I was
involved in the youth I was like
secretary um only secretary of the
women's
obviously um sometimes we get combined
with the men but often times it's kind
of very you kind of stay in your own sex
group so you're always with women or and
the men are always with the men the boys
are with the boys the girls are with the
girls unless you're like atal lisence
and obviously they're all together but I
feel that there is definitely there is
definitely um segregation within women
and men in the church I do believe that
they hold more power I feel like it's
not as
inclusive as it should be so so it seems
like both sides can agree that you know
the debate is on whether it's unequal or
not but they do have different roles and
responsibilities uh in that instance I
think I like to speak did that impact
whether you left or not I I think it did
impact my my involvement in the church
in general because what I love the way
that you're explaining is like a kid a
kid can sit in church and see who is in
charge a child can uh even being raised
you know becoming a teenager you were
only involved with the women even be
like all of these levels all the way up
to a level of an adult of being married
of you can only practice your sexuality
once you're married to a man only can
you have sexual relationships once
you're married to a man like it's very
clear that we as women are seen very
differently and not only that but even
the concept of of a heavenly mother that
we talk about they just told us to that
we're not allowed to pray even to a
heavenly mother we're not even allowed
to it's not brought up we don't talk
about it and that just so clearly
displays the difference of we only speak
to God the Father we don't speak to God
mother we don't talk about her and
what's funny is it's all of the white
men who are telling us why it's always
the white men who are telling us where
our level is it's the white men who are
saying oh no you have equal priesthood
but you can't sit on the stand you can't
pass a Sacrament you can't bless people
can't baptize people I'm sorry but that
was that is a
judeo multi-racial
Biblical teaching that wasn't just
instituted by white men that you may
disagree with it and that's fine sexist
nonetheless you may disagree with it but
the the fact of the matter is is that
there always is someone who presides
okay and the scriptures say that the one
who presides in the household is the man
but presiding doesn't mean is higher
than okay or has more power over it
means he just has the husband has to
ensure that the needs of the household
are taken care of spiritually and
temporally and he works with his wife to
do that but it doesn't mean he has more
power over her but going oh I'm actually
curious to hear his thoughts
as this this little conversation right
here is a microcosm of my Mormon
experience which is it's men having the
power men dominating the conversation
and then telling women why they're more
important while they're mostly silent
when you were speaking about heavenly
mother when I first was speaking with
the missionaries and learning more about
the church um obviously you're always
talking about Jesus Christ and the
heavenly father and all the Holy Ghost
and all these things and I don't know
where but I C I was thinking about it I
came across it I was like well I want to
learn more about heavenly mother and it
was probably a one and a half minute
conversation because oh we don't know
anything about heavenly mother I was
like well why do we know all these
things and we don't know anything about
heavenly mother I was like she should be
equally important I mean she birthed the
person we worship so I just it was I
couldn't fathom how we knew little to
nothing about it's not even that we
speak less of her it's we don't speak
speak her I'm not allowed to we're not
even allowed to pray to her well I I
would well just cuz you're not allowed
to pray to something other than and by
the way not allowed I I think that's
misrepresentation to you have free
agency you could do whatever you want
but just because we don't have codified
prayer to somebody other than our Father
in heaven doesn't mean that we hate like
but the prophet told us not to yeah okay
well I actually got a question for you I
got a question for you girls um the
division oh okay so this this always
atrophies into a priesthood argument um
but do you think it's possible to have
equality with a division of labor or
would equality be achieved in your mind
with women receiving the priesthood and
then have a follow-up this came to my
mind this isn't a Goa but what would
satisfy your definition of equality must
the women be given the priesthood and
that's the the hill we dying on here or
is there any other definition that would
satisfy
you I think just being able to see at
least one woman up there leading the
congregation for at least half of the
well well Define leading like having an
important job other than I think the
women are only allowed to be leaders of
the women whereas the men can be leaders
of both men and women above all the
church so if if women could have higher
up roles where they are given more
responsibility and more people in the
congregation to care for and look after
and given more positions of power
something equivalent to the priesthood
maybe not the priesthood but at least
equivalent so then then what would you
call like for example sister Espen house
I can't name the heads of the Relief
Society but the young women I can
because I'm a little bit more uh uh
aware of it because I have children that
are youth but sister espenau Emily B
Freeman all of these women um uh that
that have wildly powerful positions
within the Church of Jesus Christ of
latterday saints I mean Emily B Friedman
is probably one of the single most
powerful Mormons in the world I would
say if she put something out on
Instagram it would probably have almost
as much pull as Russell M Nelson in the
Pacific Northwest and this side of the
Rockies so um if if we you were to give
just women the priesthood magically all
of a sudden right now it seems like
these arguments kind of come from a
politically secular leftist uh stance of
like representation which I get I
understand movies are cooler when you
see somebody that looks like you in it I
get that but then would you want to
preach from a Bible that's almost
written wholly and completely by men at
that point would the demands of equality
require that we have equal
representation in the books there's only
one Book of Esther now we'll take one
book out of the septu aent and ignore
the Book of Mormon because there's not a
single one that's written by a a woman
like I don't see unless we accept the
dichotomy that there can be equality
with a division of labor I don't see
where it
ends even after giving women the
priesthood and this is this is an honest
question I think it's even taking a
bigger step back from even just having a
position of power but like first of all
yes I do think that women should be in
be able to be a position of power it is
the whole doctrine of the church that
how of how women are seen and how they
were treated it's bigger than just a
position it's how they are treated it's
like these are their responsibilities
this is the women's responsibility in
the doctrine of the family proclamation
it says very clearly what a woman's job
is and what a man's job is and guess who
wrote that bunch of white men did any of
the women get to write that or present
it no the man did do a w do women get to
even be a prophet no there's never been
a woman prophet and so we always have
these assumptions but it really is how
women are treated in general and how
they are seen of their position in the
church as a whole not just by okay you
can be over all the women congrats you
have a big Instagram it's bigger than
that it's okay for the doctrine to
change there's scriptural precedent for
it changing and one of the most
beautiful aspects of the Church of Jesus
Christ lattery of saints is the fact
that we have and rely upon modern
prophets and we take what they say
seriously and look forward to that
prophetic Revelation but at the end of
the day um we still have to go home and
get that same revelation we have to get
that same answer from God directly from
him that
dovetails with that Revelation so that
we know in our core that um that is what
God wants for his children uh we don't
have a stat at God I just I disagree
there because God is unchangable as it
states in the scriptures the the there
are Eternal principles that are eternal
they never change but how those
principles are applied can change over
time but the the Eternal principles
remain the same period if we don't have
any object objective solid Eternal truth
then everything is relative and
relativity leads to chaos we're talking
about understanding God and eternal
principles I mean we're talking about
Cosmic law multi-dimensions everything
so expansive
and all that information part of it is
being channeled through the mind of
fallible people who are writing things
down in a fallible language being
interpreted to people with fallible
understanding modern times you need
modern measures so it's useful that we
have prophets on this Earth to this day
because everything is Ever Changing I
mean look at our language and look at
the way it used to be look how it is now
I it's just everybody needs an updated
interpretation one of my favorite things
about the mor mature is how much has
changed and I can think about three
issues that really troubled me when I
was a Orthodox devout member one was
when I went through the temple for the
first time and I had to slip my throat
um as part of uh use my hand my thumb as
a sign to slip my throat as part of a
covenant I was making in the temple I
was super glad when I found out they
took that out in 1990 the second was I'm
old enough uh to remember when when
Black Mormons were not allowed to hold
the priesthood they were not allowed to
hold certain offices in the church and
when they were kept out of the temple
with just basic Temple blessings and I
was super happy in 1978 when they
allowed black people to be members in
full standing the final one uh my
grandmother was the daughter of a third
wife so I come directly from a
polygamous ancestry and it was until I
was 30 or 31 that I found out that the
founder of Mormonism Joseph Smith
married over 30 women 14year olds other
men's wives I was that information was
withheld for me for 30 years and uh I
was super happy uh that over time the
church has distanced itself from
polygamy because I think it's one of the
most horrendous teachings that the
church has ever had so I'm super
grateful the church changes and it does
I have to push back because I think
there's there's some things that are
misconstrued as doctrine that are
policies um and we we we see that as the
church which thing which thing that I
just said was a miscon uh blacks not
receiving the priesthood isn't that just
a fact well no but you're saying it was
a doctrine that changed well the first
presidency the the prophet in the first
and second counselor prior to 1978 on
multiple occasions signed statements
saying that it was doctrine that that
black people could not be members in
full standing that's the first
presidency in the 1940s and 50s yeah but
that was a Corruption of the Joseph
Smith baptized freem men he had a
presidential platform based upon
abolition the Mormon church was
basically an abolitionist entity that
the government feared in the West for
its first 50 years the fact that it
adopted some bad ideas of the curse of
Cain because of protestant influence
coming from the south especially when
parley Patt returned as a missionary
from the south and the pressures put on
Brigham Young as a governor of the state
of Deseret that is that is an abuse of
History to say but it's your prophets
the people that you believe claim spoke
to God and that I used to believe
they're the ones signing these
statements it's David omay it's it's
people that you sustain as propers and
revelators so how do you know when
they're speaking as a man how do you
when when they're excluding entire race
of people from Full participation how do
you know they're speaking for God or
speaking for themselves until the social
I answered that right at the beginning
of this whole uh this whole entire
prompt that it's a two-part path you
receive Revelation from a prophet you go
home you pray about it you confirm it
like I actually really appreciate this
question
because it gets to the root of
epistemology should we let qu who answer
this I I think I think the the human ego
speaks when we want our environment and
the bubble we're we're in cuz everyone
lives in a bubble we don't want that
bubble to change no matter what human
beings are prideful human beings have
ego everyone does I look at some of the
things our church leaders said David oay
right brigam young Joseph Fielding Smith
I know they weren't you know singing
Kumbaya with black people I get that you
know I totally get that but at the same
time I understand that people are also
products of their environment and I
don't want to condemn someone who's not
here to defend themselves and in the
same way a 100 years from now someone
will look at us and they'll say oh my
gosh I I can't believe you guys were
using your your your Cobalt iPhones
built by child slaves please don't deny
my Humanity 100 years from now well look
look at a new testament example Peter
Peter was the leading apostle during the
time of the original Apostles right and
he was making Gentile converts get
circumcised and Paul confronts him to
the face saying that this isn't
necessary so you have disagreement
within the apostleship and but doesn't
The Book of Mormons say that God cursed
white people with dark skin for their
wickedness doesn't isn't that in your
scriptural Canon it depends on it
depends on your
interpretation what's your
interpretation well there's there's
scriptures in the Old Testament where
certain individuals say there's a skin
of Blackness upon me that is totally uh
symbolic of being in a state of distress
or I am black become Leo so what did God
do to the lonit in the Book of Mormon in
your interpretation did he not turn
their skin dark because of their
wickedness even though the book says
that no no I I think it was a spiritual
Mark just like with Cain we don't know
but it says skin of Blackness in the
book of morm it says skin of Blackness
it's an idiom there
idioms that are mated doesn't feel
convenient to call it an idiom when it
says of black because you need to and
when they when it talks about their dark
skin that that that that they God made
them dark so that they'll be loathsome
to the white skin because if you're a
Biblical and Greek scholar you realize
there are there are idioms like this one
which is well known in in uh ancient
scripture as being a symbol of being a
dist as a dark can I speak um so uh I've
never read it that way the Book of
Mormon is by and large about Native
Americans and whenever we bring up the
subject of race suddenly it turns into
Europeans being switched into subsaharan
Africans but that that's not what the
book is saying when I read the book of
Mormon I'm seeing Nephi which is where
this comes from the you know this the
the cursing Nephi hates the lamanites
he's finding every single way to dislike
them and then his brother Jacob comes
and says hey you should not hate them
because they're darker than you and then
Samuel the lonite the dark Prophet is
speaking to the white Nephites and he's
saying hey no you're actually cursed and
they say let's remove him from the
record and Jesus comes in and says put
him back in the record it's showing a
history of prejudice and how to overcome
it so what do what does skin of
Blackness mean in the book yeah Nephi
may very well believe that Jacob doesn't
that doesn't mean it's prescriptive that
means it's descriptive so you're saying
you're saying To Kill a Mockingbird is
racist you're saying Nei was racist but
not God um I'm
saying possibly I you it's it's
effectively Diaries right that's
Co prompt
wasn't whether the doctrine can change
it was is it okay for the doctrine to
change and I feel like that puts the
church into a very precarious situation
especially going back to our last
discussion when you said something
that's still kind of in my head the
doctrine the abuse of the doctrine of
Eternal family can the doctrine of
Eternal family is it okay for the the
doctrine of Eternal family to change
within the LDS
church uh is it okay uh again I would
just say I guess Define okay uh is there
a scriptural precedent for it and it
could yes absolutely if a prophet were
to come out and say I've received a
revelation from God and um X is going to
change and
then you know he announces it in general
conference and I go home and pray about
it time goes and about we realize okay
cool this is a revelation from God it's
changing what about the families that
lost so many sons and daughters to
suicide because of that never changing
doctrine of specific Eternal families
you cannot go to Celestial Kingdom
because you believe in this we'll be
able to visit you every now and again
we'll have a little family reunion that
kind of thing but you just can't come
and and visit us up there if that
changes the the LDS Church is I mean
they tried to do a little change jaro in
2015 where they were like you know
children of you know same-sex households
can't get baptized and that was changed
real quick and my parents and my parents
but but we're we're talking about would
you want me question or yeah oh
definitely so first off individually
just manto man friend to friend if well
hopefully we'll become friends um if
somebody actually said that to you what
you just articulated right there that is
not Christ Doctrine applied through
Christlike love there's three or four
things that are wrong with what has
happened to you guys if you guys are
indeed regurgitating the story the way
it happens and I believe you so on an
individual level I want to say I I I see
you I I validate what you've gone
through and my first initial reaction
would be first to very quickly delineate
between the church with a little sea and
a church with a big sea I will tell you
the church with the big sea and its
codified doctrines is loving to all
gives an an eternal immeasurable value
to every soul and and Views you first as
a child of God not as a gay man not as
an ex-husband to a woman or a current
husband to a man it sees you as as as
who you are with that said we all have
really cringy awkward friends who've
said incorrect sometimes maybe even
cruel things to lgbtq members justified
by false conceptions of God or
misinterpretations of Doctrine and their
bigotry they have tried to couch in
religious writ or religious culture and
that is wrong simultaneously if we're
talking about is it okay that Doctrine
changes yes there's a completely totally
codified runway for how a Doctrine can
change in our church and it is okay for
us as members
because there's a mechanism for
recognizing that as the Revelation for
the LDS church to delineate between
policy and Doctrine because if they
change certain things that they've
deemed Doctrine they're I think the
problem is is it keeps changing and what
happens is the prophet will say
something and then he says this is this
is God's word and he does something like
how youth couldn't get baptized if they
were the children of queer parents but
then it swaps say when he said this is
doct this came from God he did and then
it swapped back so the problem that I
have is that it's not that policies or
things can change it's the fact that
we're constantly attributing things to
God yes and then when it changes again
we're like oh it was policy oh it's a
fallacy of man what kills me is like I
was taught that God is the same
yesterday today and forever and so on
one hand I feel like Doctrine shouldn't
change and when we do see the changes
happening a lot of the time it's because
of social media it's because of
headlines it's because of the church
trying to become more acceptable in
society and so with Doctrine like
polygamy was one now it's like an flds
thing but it was once practiced by the
mainstream church now it's been
disavowed we no longer do polygamy and
technically it's is practi in heaven in
heaven polygamy will be practiced it's
the way it's the law of Heaven polygamy
and so I feel like it's been disavowed
here on Earth to like appease society
and yet in heaven so so to summarize
like you're essentially saying that
whenever there's social pressure that
changes it it gets put into policy think
it's okay for
not to be a jerk but this just sounds
like and and I don't mean this to be
disrespectful but it sounds like you're
just having a gripe like yes you can be
frustrated that things have changed back
and forth but it is good for
organization to change for the better I
don't understand how anyone could say
it's wrong for Doctrine to change so I
came out in the prompt because I'm
grateful that the church has made these
changes the problem is is that they
don't own up to the mistakes they've
made they've never apologized to to
black people for excluding them for over
a century the problem is that when the
church teaches something as Doctrine to
all its members and it leads to Carnage
whether it's lgbtq deaths destruction of
families systemic racism for over 150
years the church never owns up and
apologizes and says hey sorry black
people we excluded you for 150 years
sorry parents of LGB and siblings of
lgbtq Youth sorry that your kids died
the church just says up uh that was just
that was just policy that they were all
speaking as men but then they turn
around and say but if the prophet but if
the prophet speaking now you have to
obey the prophet you have to follow the
prophet so the church never the church
never atones it never does what it asks
the members to do I'm I'm saying this
with as much grace as I can muster our
beloved Prophet Russell M Nelson you
know he is nearly 100 I'm not kidding 99
he's 99 and he is running a global
organization when he was going into
college the prophet of our church at his
time was still a polygamist right I mean
we're talking about old old people that
he was born before the television queen
the former Queen of England and Martin
Luther King and has outlived two of
those three things okay so again give
him Grace he like these people are doing
the best but then what's the value of a
prophet like do you believe he talks to
God the value of a prophet is look at
the people he talks directly to God I I
face to face maybe I don't know but like
God tells him the truth that he needs to
know for the world today is what you
believe we're talking about a beautiful
Cosmic entity that is Heavenly Father
trying to channel information through a
99y old man in Salt Lake City he does
yes oh yeah to you as well yeah but it
gets so am I Prophet I don't know are
you the Mormon church has done good in
the world agers please St
forward we do a lot of humanitarian Aid
uh we give wheelchairs out to people and
in like third world Nations uh I mean
there's a lot of good we do um I would
agree that I would also say you know
there's there's some things that other
religions do better than us the the LDS
church does a great job helping out
those who are needy I think the church
does do a lot of great humanitarian work
and a lot of the time growing up it was
like what can we do for our neighborhood
what can we do for our church Community
what can we do for our fellow Ward
members they just preach a lot of
service qualities which is great um I on
the other hand I think that I mean I
hate to say they could do more and
that's the negative
but like with all of the money that they
inherit from tithing the Mormon Church
requires its members give 10% of their
income for taxes to the Mormon church
and then they utilize that money to do
things you know around the world um like
build malls um but I think that they
could do more with the money they're
doing yes they do a lot of good but I
think they could do even more good if
they utilize that money better when I
personally had a surgery and
I had random members that I probably
haven't even met from my church they
were leaving me gifts they were leaving
me notes they were leaving me cards just
get well soon not nothing nothing huge
but it's just the thought that counts
and um I didn't even have family that
would leave me things like that they're
just very thoughtful people and they're
always thinking of the next guy for
especially the ex Mormons would you guys
say it's more of a net positive or a net
negative for me it's going to be more of
a net positive and I know that's kind of
surprising to probably a lot of people
here um I left the Mormon church just a
few years ago because I just it didn't
make me personally happy I I get to kind
of sit here today in a little bit of a a
happy position just knowing that like I
don't really feel like I have a lot of
religious trauma to speak of about the
my you know my experience in the Mormon
church I feel like I when I went on my
mission I was called to Houston Texas I
got to meet some amazing people and the
things that I taught in preach my gospel
that spoke to me that I still know to
this day are true are all of the things
that I still keep in my life that I hold
dear that I associate um you know the
friends that I have the family that I
that I keep the just all the connections
that I have are within those truths that
I hold dear so for me I'm going to go
ahead and just say it's a net positive
for me and I'm really thankful for that
when I was in Middle School my parents
got divorced and uh I think my life
could have gone in a lot of directions
at that point and uh I remember one of
my Mormon church leaders has pulled me
aside and he said John you're a star and
so many good Mormon adult leaders rally
arounded rallied around me supported me
um and uh provided me with an amazing
youth experience and then I went on to
serve a mission in Guatemala I learned a
foreign language I spent two years in a
developing country and uh and then just
in my psychology training people need
identity meaning purpose morality a
sense of spirituality resolution about
the afterlife and friends and community
and one of the things that I regret is
I've spent so much time trying to create
secular Community after being kicked out
of the Mormon church and I have not been
able to do anything like what the Mormon
church has been able to do so until
secular people are able to create
communities that that provide all these
those things to the secular people I
think religions like the Mormon Church
are going to continue to um have an
important Place yeah I could say that a
lot of the opportunities that I
experienced a lot of the mentors a lot
of the people that helped the village
that raised me was within my church
experience and so my mission I had
positive experiences I've met a lot of
incredible people built a lot of good
connections but I don't know that I mean
I know yeah there's humanitarian stuff
but I don't know if you can weigh that
to the youth suicide in the lgbtq
Community I don't know if we can weigh
that it's just it's just hard to weigh
those things out of like is the good
better than the negative because of the
spiritual trauma that it does cost the
the emotional damage it does within
families within individuals so I don't
know that I could actually say which it
does more of because the damage is so
severe but I know that there are
positive experiences I can't have
conversations like this with my family
it's not a way we speak with each other
we can't have this open dialogue of what
we disagree about and you know maybe
other families are different but my
family is very very Mormon in that way
where very reactive and uncomfortable
topics don't go well and if I want to
talk about the history or or people of
lgbtq it's not a conversation I can have
so having this conversation with all of
you today almost was like a substitute
for that so you need him to come like
family din that's like that be great I'm
I'm not
cheat um well so that concludes our
episode of Mormons versus Mormons if you
guys want to embrace shake hands hug
what you guys need to
do and then I got to go to the
bathroom have we met
[Music]
before